i think one of the things that she kind
of confused and we've talked about it
too openly that
she goes it's easier for you i'm like no
it's not easier for me i started way
earlier
it's the battle happened since i was
like i don't know
15 16 and it went on and on and on and
on and it's still going on until this
day in five four
three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
brand new episode of the genius brain
podcast if you are a first time listener
well guess what i'm introducing you to
the new [ __ ] studio space
i'm over here with studio 71 shout outs
to them right there genius brain new
studio i don't have to edit my own [ __ ]
i got robin couch in the back hell yeah
and we have julia chao here today
thank you julia it's been so long since
you've been on this podcast your hair is
blue as ever you pokemon freak
yeah i i thought with this girl the
other day this [ __ ] came in a pikachu
tank top i was like yo where the [ __ ]
did you buy this [ __ ] did i come into
pikachu you had a pikachu jersey
you don't you don't even watch anime
like that
what are you talking about wait what do
you mean a pokemon jersey i think the
last time i talked to you though we hung
out was when we were walking out no full
you met up at junior rolling heights
what are you talking about
i don't remember what i wore that day
you wore a yellow pikachu jersey
all right yeah that's right okay yeah my
[ __ ] words it's true it was uh
created by creators guild by the way
it's really nice we were talking about
it uh on the way here yeah one of the
craziest [ __ ] car accidents happened
not not on the road to us but in la
i'm not sure if you guys saw this on the
news but there was a lady
who drove on an in an intersection
straight blasted through the
intersection at like 100 miles per hour
and [ __ ] smashed into like two cars
and it exploded on site and of course
when something like this happens who who
doesn't die
the driver the person who's the [ __ ]
driver so i was reading up about this
the other day and
she was trying to commit suicide yeah
because her [ __ ] boyfriend dumped her
dude but like is that confirmed though
because though that like from what i've
seen the sources is from her friend it
was like oh yeah you know she's having a
rough patch with her boyfriend and then
there was speculation like i've seen
like i think a few tick tock videos
where like people are saying if you zoom
in on the surveillance footage and you
uh look into like the i guess the car
that she was driving she was eating a
burrito you see a little like dot like
outside the window that consistently
follows a car so people are speculating
that it's her arm that was out as she
was facetiming her boyfriend and saying
i'm going to [ __ ] do it that's what
people are speculating is that really
literally facetiming her boyfriend and
trying to i don't know if that's true i
don't know if that's true at all but
people are going ham on like
figuring out what happened and like what
that dot is and like if her arm was
actually really sticking out and if she
really did it to commit suicide because
her boyfriend dumped her
that's i have never heard of that theory
that's [ __ ] nuts god go on tick-tock
that's okay don't worry about that [ __ ]
this ain't jk news you could have a
couple of ding-dongs every now and then
sorry yeah that's [ __ ] crazy like
when i saw that video because i think um
a woman who was pregnant died right yes
a woman who was pregnant died her
husband and i think like her kid in the
back also died too so entire family died
so six people died and then eight people
were injured and she was left with like
an armed that she like left with an
injured arm and i guess like that arm
was also the one that people are
speculating that she had outside the
window
that's [ __ ] grippy dude i've you know
it's i actually had a conversation with
like um
a buddy of mine he's a doctor and he was
telling me that uh
he deals with like a lot of female
patients who have
his female patients versus his male
patients like when they get to know them
and when you're like a general physician
you know you have conversations with a
lot of people um he says a lot of these
patients have to go through like female
patients who are going through a lot
have a lot of like suicidal ideations
compared to his compared to men i'm not
sure if that's like statistically true
or not but that's pretty [ __ ] nuts
because i i've said this on this podcast
before i've never ever thought about
killing myself i've never had that
thought so i don't know what it feels
like to to be in a position where you
feel like you
want to take your life especially for
something like i don't know getting
dumped right which that probably is just
a catalyst for you know
something completely else so something
else outside of just the breakup but
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy well i kind
of i mean but like also keep in mind
though that she works in the medical
field and the past two years have been
crazy
yeah
you're surrounded with a lot of deaths
yeah yeah especially because of uh uh
covet and stuff yeah shout outs to cove
that got me twice you stupid sons of
[ __ ] [ __ ] got me twice
shout out to my friend eunice who gave
it to me you stupid super spreader idiot
she [ __ ] did she know she didn't know
that she was uh she didn't feel
symptomatic at all but you know
she's kind of like in the like the film
industry so she's traveling around a lot
yeah and then she messaged me when i
so i already left the sacramento to see
my parents yeah so i was in sacramento
and she goes hey just let you know i
found out i have coveted
so uh but i messaged her i was like i
already have it dude
so you were the one that [ __ ] gave it
to me you super spreading [ __ ]
but it was uh it wasn't that bad the
second time around yeah i uh literally
i the only reason why i thought i had
kovit was because i took two naps and i
never take naps i don't i'm not sleepy
like that like i have trouble sleeping
so when i took those two naps it felt
odd like my something was off yeah i
took the test i saw a very faint second
line i'm like covet i [ __ ] have covet
dude but it wasn't bad though the first
time i literally thought i was going to
die i remember that i remember i
messaged you about it and you're like
dog i'm in a hotel right now and i'm
crying because i can't taste anything
not even that i just couldn't go
anywhere so i would just watch people
look from the window yeah and then
pasadena went on lockdown
so my only source of entertainment was
people watching
so
there was no there was nobody to look at
anymore so i cried i'm like that was my
only source of entertainment
you told me you cried because you
couldn't taste anything
all together the idea behind that was
okay i caught coven fine whatever i get
to be away from the lady a little bit
i'm gonna book this nice ass hotel in
pasadena and
i'm just gonna post mates food i'm a
postmates food and then i'm gonna jack
off and i'm gonna feel fantastic
i get there
i order a fat burger i get uh chicken
wings right okay
i get these lemon pepper chicken wings i
get the blue cheese dressing on the side
i get their their bacon double
cheeseburger or whatever fat burger i
sit down i have the sprite i drink the
sprite i'm like ah they didn't put
enough syrup in this [ __ ] it tastes
whatever fine i ate the wings i'm like
these wings are [ __ ] bland yeah and i
go take a bite a third bite
and then no taste
so it my taste literally disappeared as
i was eating yeah so it went from oh
this soda doesn't taste like anything
they forgot to put syrup in it all these
wings are kind of whack
bit into the burger
nothing oh my gosh no taste and i
[ __ ] freaked out i'm like so now all
i have is jacking off but then guess
what i had body aches i had a fever
couldn't even jack off everything was
taken from me couldn't go outside i
couldn't people watch nothing i was so
[ __ ] sad the first thing i tasted
banana pudding
it was on day seven oh and then
i could barely taste it like a face
so what it's so throughout the time
where you couldn't taste how did you eat
like did you just force yourself to eat
like was that really hard for you one
thing i could let you guys know if you
ever get coveted your skin's gonna look
super good dude
because all you're doing is drinking
water
and you're eating healthier things
because you want to speed up the
recovery well because the thing about
that is this is
you
eat food for pleasure right which is why
somebody who's a fat [ __ ] like me i eat
out of joy
well when you don't have taste there's
no joy to it so the only thing that
you're left with is how the food makes
you feel
so
uh the foods that because you're not
tasting anything right and you're only
looking for texture what has texture
[ __ ] salad fruits
right
it's very hydrating and then all these
foods that are less greasy not fried or
whatever there's no point in me getting
fried food i can't even [ __ ] taste it
why would i eat it i guess that makes
sense that you still have sensations
yeah so that's the only thing you're
looking for and then there's no point in
eating chips and the reason why once
again is because you're only left with
how the food makes you feel so when i
ate chips because i didn't have taste it
was only the the chips didn't make me
feel good
i could imagine just being really
crunchy and soggy all right it looks
crazy you just take you just feel the
grease in your mouth with no taste so
there's nothing to balance any of that
[ __ ] out so i just naturally was eating
less calorically dense food and just
food with higher nutrition and then i
lost like 10 pounds yeah and then my
skin was amazing i remember i just
looked at my skin one day and i went
holy [ __ ] you are beautiful
like look at this [ __ ]
just and
you shouldn't you should you should have
shot a skincare ad
i should have they would pay me or give
me some [ __ ] money dude yeah we were
talking about in the car but you said
that you were you're uh going to therapy
now right yeah
hella people during pandemic starting
with therapy yeah yeah which is a good
thing just because you know i think that
a lot of us
we don't ever get to think about our own
thoughts and kind of
you know when i was learning through uh
i forgot like you know different levels
of like attachment how people deal with
issues right but i feel like a majority
of the people that i know are typically
very very avoided like they don't
they'll kind of dance around these
issues because they don't have to so
like with pandemic
it happened to a lot of couples and i
knew a lot of couples who split yeah
um like i've talked about on the podcast
where me and mariel we had to be faced
with each other a lot right so because
during this time
she and i didn't see each other much in
the first place even when we lived in
the same house because she was always
working and at the time the job that she
was working at it was just always long
[ __ ] hours and then i was traveling
around doing zen foods so we would
barely see each other so a lot of the
issues that we had we didn't have to
deal with
oh
it was like always postponed until then
postponed we just didn't know that there
were so many things we didn't like about
each other
and so when we had to sit there every
day
and i was at the house and i was doing
things that she didn't like so for
example it would be like there'd be
dishes in the sink or all this other
stuff but by the time she would come
home from work i was it would already be
clean but i would wait off until like
before she comes and then i do it so i
kind of stack it up and then wash it but
when she's at the house every day she
just looks at it she goes he didn't
clean his dishes
but in my mind i'm like no it's going to
be clean but you weren't here before so
by the time you came home it was all
done right so there were these little
small things that would add up and then
we found out that there was other small
things that we didn't like and then
we fit we were faced with this idea of
like oh [ __ ] there's i [ __ ] don't
like you
you know
i don't like you at all and uh mary
marielle started going to therapy during
uh pandemic and it helped her out a lot
yeah yeah because she didn't really
i think a lot of people don't believe in
the power of therapy
um
only because like therapy has like a
weird feeling behind it i mean you know
something's wrong with you or like
confronting every issue you have in your
life a lot and listen listen like that's
the hard part the therapy right
having to be vulnerable enough to talk
to somebody that you don't know which
which honestly is the best because you
don't have to worry about them judging
you right and then having to sit there
and fix the problems that you know have
been there for a very long time but you
didn't want to face right because if you
have that avoidant behavior
you just you can you can dodge it all
the [ __ ] time dude that's like
literally what i was just telling so
like
i wanted to go just so i can like put
like my best foot forward right like
trying to live my best life you know but
like what what is what is going up with
me what can i improve on right and i
think like one of the things that have
been like really frustrating for me
was that like i
i have an idea of like what kind of
relationship i want with my parents
and i feel like
it's kind of hard to do that without
having to like just swallow your
feelings a lot of the times
and then another part was just like me
getting frustrated about like you know i
say a lot of things and i say things out
loud because i i want to have meaning to
it but then like i can't seem to like
follow through with it right so like you
know how all the bajillion times that
i've like filmed with you david i'll be
like yeah check out my youtube channel
but then like i've never like actually
like maybe i post like one or two but
like in like what how many years right
yeah and i just kind of felt like i say
it because i really mean it but then
like a part of like i'm like i feel like
i'm halfway there like i have it but
then like i just need to finish the rest
of the half to it and like i just
couldn't i just didn't know why right
like i didn't know
what was like preventing me from like
getting to that other half and so um
going to therapy about that she was just
like it seems like you're just avoiding
a lot of certain feelings and i was like
feelings huh
she was just like yeah like it just
seems like because like um a thing that
i tend to do is i talk myself out of it
like a lot of things right where it's
just like oh yeah you know i wanna i
wanna do youtube video and then like as
i'm like doing is like oh i don't know
about this like maybe i should change it
like that and then like i make it way
more complicated than it needs to be and
then i just end up not doing it because
i was like whatever man like at this
point i'm like i can't do it like i'm
overwhelmed now at this point and with
my parents it's like well it's mainly
like
with my mom like my dad
he's pretty chill for the most part like
he just he's very supportive and he's
like you know like i want you to do
whatever you want to do
and then with my mom it's like
she like nitpicks at me for like a lot
of things i mean like it it
i feel like it's expected to happen
because you know i am still like her
child and like i'm living at like home
right and i'm sure that you know she has
like her home like she wants her home to
be a certain way but i think it also
hurts to see her child like not
necessarily taking care of herself
really well and i think like do you feel
um and i think i've seen this theme so
much with uh young asian girls where do
you feel that when you set boundaries
with your mom
that you feel like you're being a bad
daughter oh of course 100 of the time
yeah like i yeah i've heard that so
often yeah
not being able to stand up to your
parents because you feel like you're
you're failing your parents as a good
kid like i am a good kid so when my
parents tell me to do something i do it
and when you don't do that even if it
hurts you yeah it makes you feel
it's weird because it makes you feel
good that you're being
a good child but being a good child
takes away from your humanity right you
being an adult because as a certain
point when you're an adult you have to
make your own choices yeah yeah and um
like a lot of like asian homegirls like
dealt with this
right i am a good girl i've always been
a good person i'm a good girl if i talk
back to my parents that i'm a bad person
yeah exactly yeah and i just remember
like
just trying to set boundaries with my
mom even prior to therapy like you know
i would usually like just throw a fit
right but then after i throw the fit i'm
like oh i just feel like a [ __ ] brat
because like i just threw a fit and i
was angry at her when maybe like she had
a valid point right
and i i just feel like
like okay so one of the the
the more reoccurring things is like the
amount of food that i eat right i think
i eat just fine like i'm not trying to
like skimp out or anything it's just
that if i'm full i'm full right like a
normal human being like if i'm full
but like not an asian household
let me tell you look at that plate what
you're not eating this plate yeah you
have any idea how many hours i spent i
raised this pig outside myself i
slaughtered it
i slaughtered this pig for you to make
this [ __ ] dumpling and you're not
gonna eat it well yeah i guess you
[ __ ] don't love me let me tell you
there was a time when i went in japan in
my sophomore year of college with like a
friend of mine and we stayed at like uh
an onsen right or ryokan i don't know
how you pronounce it but like it was an
onsen but they also had like a meal
right it was a feast it was like a huge
ass meal like it just kept bringing food
in in in all the time and i just
remember thinking like oh my god how's
two people gonna finish eating this
thing we managed to do it and i just
remember at the end of the meal i was
like gotta thank my mom for prepping me
for like these 21 years of my life
i wouldn't have been able to finish his
food without her
it was like the training of it all was
that like
she wanted us to eat so much food that
in order to get through it it was just
speed like you just had to eat you just
had to eat really fast before you get
full
yeah and so like because my mom like you
know if there was like a little bit of
leftovers like she was like oh no like
it's not gonna be good like just finish
it and you're just like literally
forcing yourself to finish it right and
so she's done that with everybody in the
family like everybody right
got to the point where it was like
sending me mixed signals as a kid where
um my mom was like oh you should eat eat
right and i'm like okay i'm eating right
and then like i see my grandma on my
mom's side and she's like oh you're so
fat and i'm like
great you know like i'm listening to my
mom and i'm eating and my mom's not
saying that fat but you grandma's there
saying that i'm fat and then it just
kept happening and then like i think i
remember like when going on a road trip
up to norcal to visit like my mom's side
of the family my mom's like oh you
should eat this and i was like no and
because i was already preparing myself
for like thinking about like what my
grandma would say right like oh you're
so fat and i was like oh sure [ __ ]
fat ass i just ate all the car right
over you know
but obviously like it was just it's just
such a battle with my mom about it right
and i know that she means well right
like i think
mom's preparing food for their kids is
like a really strong love language for
them where it's just like like i cook
this food for you because i want you to
be healthy and i want to be able to
nourish you right
but like after a certain point of time
i'm like i'm too full you're going to
make me throw up yeah yeah yeah at this
point right and i just remember like i
would have these bickering moments with
my mom and like my brother like who's
been living up in norcal for like 10
years like he'll come back down like
once a year or so right and this fight
just happened like when he was down here
and he told me he's like hey don't talk
to mom like that and i was like
excuse me [ __ ]
you haven't been living with mom this in
[ __ ] entire [ __ ] time and i was
like you have that [ __ ] audacity to
tell me not to tell mom that i'm full
and i can't eat anymore and i'm drawing
this boundary and i'm being mean on
purpose because she's not listening to
me yeah right and then in recent times
because like he moved back down and now
he's dealing with my mom a lot more
um he knows what's up now
and he was actually telling my
sister-in-law and my sister-in-law told
me she's like you know i think you'll be
happy to hear this but your brother now
appreciates the work that you've done
like
that yeah i mean like setting boundaries
with parents is it's very very difficult
yeah there's like this whole
and i think too it gets harder as you
get older too because you start becoming
a more empathetic person as you get
older like you start to understand that
your parents are people they have their
own needs their own wants and you know
that empathy sometimes starts to eat
away at you because
because you understand their plight
because you understand what they're
going through you understand why that
they're giving you all this food you
just say okay i'm just gonna have to
deal with this right and then you start
going through this whole psychological
battle where you go they're not gonna be
around here for a very long time so i
should always just make them happy
the hard part about that too is that i
think yeah that's true to a certain
extent but at what point does it become
where it takes away from you because
yeah they have a limited time on this
earthquake so do we yeah and so for the
next 20 years are you going to take away
this important thing from you your whole
life of these 20 years of life just to
make this one person happy right but the
reality of the situation is that they
can also still be happy and so can you
and there's a better solution than just
having to listen to them all the [ __ ]
time yeah and i think for mario she also
had issues with her mom too and setting
those boundaries and for her i think one
of the things that she kind of confused
and we've talked about it too openly
that
she goes it's easier for you i'm like no
it's not easier for me i started way
earlier
it's the battle happened since i was
like i don't know
15 16 and it went on and on and on and
on and it's still going on till this day
i was like the difference is i started
really early yeah so
you know she was like you weren't and i
had to tell like look you weren't around
when my father kicked me out of the
house because i wasn't a good son and i
had to live outside i didn't didn't talk
to my parents for two years but because
of that major fight that happened just
to shorten the story up
it took my father had to realize that
listen and my mom told him this because
she was very very good about this she
goes listen like if you want to have a
relationship with your son you're going
to have to let go of the fact that
you're you just always want to control
him he goes if you wanted a
korean-american child then or a korean
child you should have stayed in korea
but he's a korean-american and he has
all these wants and needs and all this
other stuff that he wants that he wants
to do but you don't want to do that
because you have an idea and a lifestyle
built for him yeah well that's the
lifestyle that you wanted we should have
never came here and that's your
responsibility
and so but it took a long time that's
like a year and a half of not talking to
him yeah you know and just disappearing
and kind of doing my own thing
so that was really really [ __ ] hard
um but having to set those boundaries
early on and by the way even afterwards
i moved back in the house and we kind of
reconciled a lot of our stuff it didn't
fix it immediately right we fought we
cried we yelled at each other scream
like screamed at each other broke things
for another like six seven years and
then only until like i say about like
six years ago or so we haven't really
got into fights yeah but it took
that boundary setting of me and saying
like listen i understand you you had
this but you can't do this to me anymore
yeah and like one of the first
boundaries that i set with my parents my
dad had a
he had this uh habit of calling me
stupid and i told him like
the reason why i stopped talking to him
for about a year and a half because i
set this boundary with him i said hey
do say whatever you want be mad at me
whatever frustrated don't ever call me
stupid you call me stupid you'll never
see me again yeah well he called me
stupid one more time and that's why i
left the house but he i called his blood
he didn't think that i would do that
right because i'm his son
i own you i you do as i tell you to
because i always know what's best for
you well if he knew what was best for me
i wouldn't be doing what i'm doing now
yeah and uh when we had another our last
our last major major fight was because
he
you know parents tend to have a
selective memory
you know yeah yeah yeah they sure do
they sure do a lot of the [ __ ] that they
do to you they go that never happened
okay and then how [ __ ] mad does that
make you feel it makes you feel [ __ ]
infuriated yeah because it's super
dismissive of all this [ __ ] that you've
been dealing with mentally and they go
that never [ __ ] happened yeah i know
and so my dad
oh he basically said like listen like oh
you wouldn't have been a comedian if it
wasn't for me and then that should set
off this whole [ __ ] change i hate
when they try to take credit for the
things that you do and you're just like
yeah
but in some way i mean like
do you think no there's no listen
my father is a great man yeah right
um
always always his intentions and what he
wants for me is always in the right
place right
um and i had a lot of behaviors when i
was younger that made him concern for me
so his level of protecting me was too
much yeah so for example
my dad had this habit of not allowing me
to try things yeah because if i would
try to do something and it wasn't done
in the way that he wanted it done he
would be like you don't know what you're
doing let me do it yeah yeah but when
you do that to your kids specifically
like asian parents do this a lot or it
might be an immigrant thing maybe it's
because they like being in that role of
being in charge or they want the what's
best for their kids you kind of handicap
your kid yeah i didn't know how to do so
many things going into my 20s because my
father would call me stupid push me
aside and he would just do it for me
yeah and i got tired of that i'm like
listen just let me [ __ ] do it
let me fail let me try and the funny
thing is is that
the the part that made me really
infuriated was that he used to get mad
at me because i wouldn't i wouldn't know
how to do things oh my goodness i'm like
it's because of you like you won't let
me try let me [ __ ] fail and
the funny thing is is that he instilled
that
quality in me but he would get mad at me
for doing the quality that he instilled
in me so i'm like this is so confusing
you're in a catch-22 i've i've had
arguments with my mom like that before
and i was just like just let me let me
make mistakes just let me do it mom just
let me do it she was like i don't want
you to do it because i wish you to get
it right the first time and i was like
why is that so bad it's like why is it
so bad to just fail she was like because
i've been through that and i don't want
you to go through that and i was like
but
but like i feel like the situation is
different you know yeah and so like you
know they
obviously you know me and my mom still
like fight about that you know or it's
just like
i want to still be able to do my own
things but then i think for her like she
has a preference of like what she wants
me to do
the hardest part about those
conversations too is like
just
when they say oh it's not so much that
we know what's best for you it's more
along the lines of i just
i don't want you to
feel this pain or or whatever but it's
like listen
you know my mom came to that realization
earlier than my dad did and it happened
in the way
i kind of realized this when she would
talk to me about
uh relationships yeah and when she
started to realize that i was my own
individual and she couldn't really
control me only because she realized
that i'm a mirror like a spinning image
of her oh he's going to do what he wants
this is who i am this is a child that i
raise yeah so and you know my mom would
say this increase
which means like you only you've only
inherited all my worst qualities
she goes how is it that you have all my
worst qualities none of my best
qualities you know
and
it's true so she kind of understood that
he has to find his own way he's gonna
have to do his own thing and my mom
and i kind of realized that when i asked
my mom when i was i was single at the
time and she said and i was like oh you
want me to be with a korean girl she
goes no it would be nice
but at the end of the day i'm not gonna
be here forever i'm going to die and so
you are going to just be left with your
own life choices and the people that
you're married with i'm not married to
the woman that you're with yeah if you
if you have a happy life with her that's
great
but
it is going to affect our relationship
because i can't speak korean to her so
it would be nice if she could speak
korean but if not i understand because i
won't be here it'll be your wife your
kid but my dad didn't understand that i
was still his son and i was under his
protection so i have to do what he what
he tells me to do
and until he came to that realization it
was just we would butt heads all the
[ __ ] time because i know what's best
for you why won't you do what's best for
you why won't you do what's best for you
or is it what's best for you
you know
and yeah that's just it's it's gonna be
something that we're gonna have to deal
with too because i've also inherited the
habits that i hated from him i inherited
it too and i found that in my
relationship with mario i i learned so
like from my therapist she was just
saying like we're going to practice
more assertive communication and i'm
like
fantastic
that's great yeah sort of communication
because like i feel like
i think i come from a very like avoidant
family like a super avoided family
because like my mom is like highly
anxious about a lot of things and she's
always worried about what other people
think about her and like what her
actions speak and she always treats
other people better
um than like um just i guess like the
people like closest right but i feel
like that also oh girl i i feel that too
oh i know what you said i know you i
know what you're saying
yeah until then so my dad so
there was a time where i was fighting
with my mom and like we just had a
disagreement and i was just standing my
ground and i just remember
uh there was a time where i went out
with my dad and we were driving in the
car and he was saying like hey you know
i gotta tell you like you know you gotta
stop fighting with your mom and i was
like why and he was like because she's
your mom and i was like oh
just because i was like
just because she's my mom doesn't mean
that i can't fight with her right and
then he was like look
trust me after all these years of
marriage as your mom it's better to just
concede and let her have her way and i
was like it's like well dad i ain't no
[ __ ] like you all right
and i basically told him i was like look
dad it's like you know you can do that
yourself but where has that gotten you
yeah yeah and i told him i was like
you're unhappy that like i know you're
unhappy right and it's like for me it's
like i'm still fighting because like i
want to change like i want us to have
like i want us to be able to like change
something about our dynamic you know
because like i don't want mom to have to
be anxious all the time right but then i
also don't want her to have to like rag
on me all the time either yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so then my dad was like i was
like oh that just like caused like so
much trouble and i was like no
i was like look i've done that before
and in the end i just got hurt i don't
want to do it anymore yeah you know and
then so he like left it at that and he
didn't really want to talk about that
but like my dad is like also like not a
very confrontational person like he's
kind of a quiet guy and then with my mom
is also the same thing right it's like
she doesn't like for something that's
very important to her she doesn't like
to confront it but then like she has no
problem just nitpicking at me and like
all of my flaws and i'm like thank you
mom thank you so much and i think i
think my therapist was basically telling
me it's like you know
like because i told her like a lot of
the times when i'm like talking to her
i'm like i know all these things i
understand all these things like i can
never control other people's actions i
can't control like what they think about
me and blah blah blah and i can't
control like with what my mom says so
she's like i just don't like what the
things that she say she says to me right
and she just basically says like you
know
uh now we just need to practice on how
you react to it like all you can do is
just how you respond to it yeah it's
like a thing that's in your locus of
control exactly and so she was saying
like yeah you know like if your mom says
like oh you're a messy person just be
like
okay
thanks you know it's just like like you
know like you don't she was she was
basically telling me you have the option
to not be angry and react to it and i
was like
that is so hard ladies oh no no that
okay
i mean that's great advice a lot easier
said than done because it's like you
know somebody just comes by you and they
go what's up [ __ ] i'm like well i have
the
option to ignore the fact that this man
called me a [ __ ] and i could just
thought that i thought way easier said
than done yeah and you know
what i'm finding out too specifically in
comments and when i you know people
message me or whatever yeah is that
because you know me i'm not an avoided
person no you're not i'm not a very
avoidant person which i think i admire
about you because like that's everything
about me or like i'm avoiding but i
admire people who can be confrontational
because i'm like man how do i get it
well now i've become somebody who's not
avoiding who's
it's not even like i'm not like that by
nature it's just how my mom is and so
i've inherited that
i'm also i but as i've gotten older i
just learned to be a lot more tactful
right because before it would be
somebody would do something that's super
annoying or you know super out of pocket
and i would tell them to shut the [ __ ]
up and get the [ __ ] away from me and now
i navigate those situations a lot better
i either stay away from those situations
or i can embarrass them in a different
in a nicer way you know so
i and i what i realized you know going
back to the whole common thing is that i
will tell stories about me being very
very abrasive and i guess like me
calling people out and other people you
know sometimes you would read comments
and they say oh that didn't happen
there's no way i'll say oh because
you're an avoidant person
i'm not that person
you know but what i'm saying is that i
think a majority of people are like that
so when they hear stories about me where
i tell these people and i have other
people on the podcast who can
corroborate these stories that i've i'm
literally like this
they don't believe it they go no way
because i don't do that because i would
never oh i would feel i would die on the
inside
i don't die on the inside i'm not a very
avoiding person when it comes to
confrontation yeah and the reason why i
say that or the reason why i live like
that is because i have a habit of having
things eat me up on the inside so i need
to fix these issues now because i need
to progress with my day yeah so for
example
uh when i was back home my parents my
brother and my dad got into a fight they
always get into a fight and the reason
why they fight till this day is because
they're [ __ ] twins
they are exactly like each other that's
why me and my mom argue right but the
difference between me and my dad my dad
and my brother me and my mom is that my
mom
me and my my me and my mother we
understand that we're so [ __ ] similar
so we can hash our [ __ ] out real quick
the problem with my brother and my dad
is they don't realize how similar they
are to each other so they always think
that they're better than each other
that's so true i feel like my older
brother is like similar to my dad in a
lot of ways because like my older
brother is quiet but he's like very
lively as well too like um you know like
he's super funny yeah right yeah yeah
you met him pretty briefly yeah yeah but
like
um yeah like with me and my mom i feel
like we're similar in a lot of ways
which is probably why we clash a lot too
yeah i mean it's gonna happen that way
too and also too because you're living
at home now yeah you're just it doesn't
matter who you're with it could be your
best friend somebody that you have
everything in common proximity makes you
go crazy because after a while just the
little things start to bother you these
small things that normally you could
just not have to worry about and mario
put it to me the best she goes
you know when we were
going through our rough patch
i go you know sometimes i feel
that you have you show more
understanding to your friends and to
your other peers than you do to your
meat you're like the person that you're
with and i think for her how she
explained it to was you know she's an
avoidant person but i can avoid issues
with other people because i'm only going
to see them once in the next two three
months so why bring up something and
ruin this moment when i'm not gonna even
see them for the next couple of months i
was like but with you i'm living with
you so it just eats at me all the time
and so i have to say it
so we had to find a perfect medium of
like listen there are times when there
are battles that should be fought and
things that you should that should be
left alone and you have to process that
in your head first before you go ahead
and [ __ ] on me there are things that i
[ __ ] up on that i have to fix those
things bring it up to me but if it's
like he left chopsticks on the table
right
put it in the sink and i'm like
you do that stuff too sometimes it
doesn't bother me because i just take it
and i just put it in the sink
i don't have to always feel like i have
to vocalize things that that bother me
all the time when i could just fix it on
the spot and then move on from it yeah
because we're not looking for each other
to be perfect human beings we're looking
we're partners we're going to fill in
the gaps that i can't fill in personally
that you're going to fill in that gap
for me and i'll do the same for you so
when we have so many things to worry
about we have to learn how to let things
go parents on the other hand asian
parents don't understand that concept
it's every little [ __ ] thing matters
and i need to address it if i don't
address it for my kids they're going to
become a shitty person if they're a
shitty person that reflects me effects
on me and the family then other people
will say you raised a piece of [ __ ]
daughter and then i have to deal with
that don't you know what i'm going
through julia yeah
exactly that's why my mom tells me all
the [ __ ] times
because like you live in a [ __ ] what
are you like seeing a chinese dynasty
like what is this you know what i mean
did you know what the emperor said about
our place like no real relax man and you
know
specifically i grew up at a church
and um the last time my mom ever said
this to me i flipped the [ __ ] out and
because i got so sick of this i heard
this my whole life was
do you understand how you reflected on
us in the korean community and i looked
at her and i said [ __ ] them i was like i
could give a [ __ ] less about them and
she's like what do you mean and i'm like
these people do not matter to me they
are gonna die i'm gonna die do you think
that i'm gonna live my life to my very
last breath based on what these people
think about us and our family when they
don't know what's going on in our
day-to-day lives yeah [ __ ] those people
they don't i don't care about them yeah
yeah and they shouldn't care about me if
their whole life revolves around them
worrying about what we do because i
don't know i shaved my head or something
so clearly i'm a gangster now this kid
who played yu-gi-oh cards
i guess i'm gang-banging on the weekends
after i [ __ ] play yu-gi-oh with my
friends relax mom like cut that [ __ ] out
but you know for us being a part of a
church community because my father was a
pastor yeah people asian people be
gossiping yeah all the [ __ ] times all
they do is gossip all the [ __ ] time
yeah but that's why my dad's not a part
of these korean churches anymore because
it was like ruining our personal family
life and it made me feel as a kid
especially you know as a pastor you're
tending to so many other people around
you you feel neglected as a child yeah
like you're so good with other people
but how come you can't show that same
loving care to me and my brother because
you're so understanding you listen to
their stories but every time i say
something you think that i'm dumb
dude i feel i feel that same way like
because my mom you know she just cuts
hair right and so like
i think he you know like i think
she really prides herself in doing that
and i think she should you know because
you know she that's that's her job you
know that's for crafty yeah that's what
she's been doing right but it gets a
little too much at times and um
i feel like
whenever she does something nice for the
family it it almost feels like at the
expense of like being her emotional
punching bag because it's like oh it's
like you know i took time out of my day
and i made you this food and you're not
even eating it and i'm just like i'm
i was like i'm sorry i didn't know that
like i didn't ask you to schedule this
time out and you know like you just you
kind of did it right and like when i say
that it sucks because it's just kind of
like i'm not trying to be
a bad daughter and it's like i'm not
trying to also be inconsiderate but it
sounds so inconsiderate because it's
like
somebody who did take time out of their
day made food for me right yeah and
that's that's your empathy side which is
a really good thing to have yeah and you
know and i'm just like [ __ ] right but
then also another part is like why are
you getting mad at me it's like where
are you getting mad at me for it's like
and how i see it now is that you know
when parents do this it becomes habit
form where to the point where originally
the idea especially when you see a kid
growing up is that i'm doing it for you
but it becomes a point where they're
doing it for themselves yeah i want to
be important in your life exactly i want
to be somebody that's still needed in
your life so i have to make this food
because if i don't make this food for
you then you don't have a purpose for me
dude you know this this other day like
literally like yesterday
my mom she so so i'm on vacation right
now right which is why i could be on
here hanging out with you right so i'm
on vacation like i was able to get like
a month off of work right just because
i haven't had a break for like the past
two years or even like several years
like it's very very asian of you yeah no
like literally like right after right
after youtube right i got a job like a
week after immediately and i honestly
thought it was gonna take me like two to
three months to find a job but i got it
like so quickly that i was like okay i
guess i'll just go with it right because
like this opportunity yeah this is my
this is my chance to be in animation
right and then
i was just working and then like two
years go by like well the [ __ ] happened
and so like i i um luckily like the next
practice i'm on um they don't
necessarily need me like right away so
like i was able to get this month off
right and so my mom knows that i'm on
vacation and just the other day she was
like he's like what good are you when
you're on vacation and i was like
i was like that is so amazing i don't
take vacations yeah exactly she was like
i said i don't take vacations you know i
was like look at you you stress the [ __ ]
out all the time go take a [ __ ]
vacation and she was literally
complaining about all the things that
she had to do which is a lot you know i
get like as a homeowner there's a lot of
things you need to tend to you know you
gotta tend to like your uh your
landscape outside right and then you
also have to clean the house and blah
blah right and it's like i'm more than
happy to help my mom with these things
right but she was just on a rampage of
just complaining about like all the
things that she needed to do right and
then how she doesn't have enough time
and then you know like she's working
he's like oh you know like i would love
to have a vacation and i told her i was
like you could you own your own business
exactly that's exactly what i told her
and i was like look i was fortunate
enough that my company is big enough
where there's people that are able to
cover me if they need somebody of like a
similar position right so that i could
take this break right and then she just
just belittled everything about it and
then she was just like ha ha i was like
i was like oh i was like i can't take a
vacation people need me and he's like
you think that my customers will wait
around for two weeks if i took a
two-week vacation and i was like yes yes
they would and she was like huh no
joke's on you they will find somebody
else and i was like we'll see that's
what i'm saying like
like your mom literally does that thing
where
you know it's like
she's basically gaslighting people you
know because it's
she's making it sound as if it's i do
this for them it's like no you do it for
you because it gives you purpose and
like i see that right and i think that's
what that what makes her like really
anxious right because she
she's in the cycle of feeling that like
she's getting fulfillment from her
customers yes because like it's a need
of hers to feel needed and to feel
wanted right and if she doesn't have
that then that just makes her really
anxious and then it just makes me think
exactly and so like i was just trying to
because there was a time where she was
telling me about a story about how there
was a customer that left and then came
back because she had a botched hair job
and she was like oh can you please fix
it you're the only one that can fix my
hair and my mom was like i charged at
the same price and she was like proud
about that and i was like why would you
do that like it's like i was like i mean
good for you that she came back to you
and she sees the value in you but it's
like you should have just charged her
more and then she was like but why and i
was like because she didn't care about
you the first time around
you know she left you so you can charge
her more if she's that desperate to get
a haircut from you right and because
like my mom was at that time too in
within that conversation she was
complaining that she couldn't charge
enough you know like because like she
wants to be able to charge but she's
afraid to charge more because she's
afraid of losing her customer base so
like a lot of the things that she's
doing like which i feel i see myself in
my mom a lot where i'm like you're
avoiding a lot of these things and like
you should just do it and just be okay
with it right
it's just it's a scary thing like i said
for her it's a dependent thing of like
to be wanted this is why she does the
food thing yeah you know she creates
this food for you because she wants to
feel like this is the pr that's why a
lot of asian parents and i'm pretty sure
other people can attest to this too i'm
not sure if you have ever asked your
parents to teach you how to cook
something and they just go i'll just do
it you know what no no my mom has
something
but i've seen this a lot especially with
my mom but i know why she does this is
because she doesn't want me to make
something that she could make because i
don't need her to make it anymore
you know it [ __ ] with her a little bit
and you know
you know for her you know if i told her
this too i was like it doesn't matter if
you think i can make it better yeah i'm
still gonna want you to make it yeah you
know because
that type of food stuff it's not just
food it's it's an emotional connection i
have towards my mom that's like our
relationship like i'm not going to
take this recipe and be like i don't
need you to make it anymore no
[ __ ] if you're going to make it
i'm going to take it from you
like it's going to like when i went back
home recently
i'm literally eating the food i take one
bite she goes what do you think i'm like
let me chew
let me swallow let me taste be quiet
and she goes i just want to know if it's
good i was like i don't know yet
let me [ __ ]
let me eat
so as i'm like eating she's just like
i'm
literally chewing the food and she goes
what's it taste like it's good i'm like
hey
let me eat in peace yeah i was like
if it wasn't good do you think i would
be devouring this food in front of you
like let me eat and then i'll tell you
it's good she goes i just want to know i
was like i can't let you know cause food
is in my mouth
get out
that's what i ate she goes did you think
it's good and i'm like
there's nothing in this bowl
there's nothing in here yeah like yeah
and i was like i'll give you the verbal
affirmation but you got to let me you
got to let me say it like don't force it
out of me
the most common one that i've been
hearing from my mom recently is is it
too salty
i honestly think she's losing her taste
at the moment
like because like i think i don't i
don't know i feel like after like a
threshold right if you've been eating
salty foods for a while all you just
wanted is to be like salty right oh for
sure like when i when i uh got done with
the whole kobe thing and you know for
those ten day or seven days seven or
eight days i was in the hotel yeah i was
only eating salads no dressing no
nothing yeah and then um a few months
after i started getting my taste back
yeah everything was hella salty like i
couldn't eat chips because it would burn
my mouth
because i'm just not used to that like
sodium level yeah
so it was super super rough but yeah you
know
it's kind of cool that you're talking
about this because i feel like a lot of
young girls in your position they also
deal with this and being super avoidant
of these situations though is very
uncomfortable at the end of the
situation
i'm not saying that
people should do this with their parents
because you're trying to you know send
them or show them up i'm saying that do
this so you could end up with a better
relationship with them yeah like have
inner peace about that yeah because
because i think you know we all have an
idea of like what we want our
relationship with our parents are and
like sometimes we kind of have to just
be flexible on that idea
because like not because like you know
like oh i just want everything to be
fine and dandy between my parents right
but like i know they're not fine and
daddy i know that like they're not happy
and it would suck for your parents to
pass away and then for you to hold
resentment towards them and i think
that's the end goal it's yeah everybody
wants to avoid the immediate discomfort
in the beginning
yeah
because it hurts yeah but a lot of great
things happen because of the discomfort
that you face is growing pains it's
literally growing pains and so you have
to face that situation to kind of work
towards something better it's going to
suck and that's the thing too sometimes
when i talk about the stuff and i talk
about my personal situations like i say
they go it's easy for you who the [ __ ]
said it was easy who in the [ __ ] like i
never said it happened overnight i'm
saying it was a struggle it was a lot of
tears a lot of fighting a lot of
screaming a lot of yelling a lot of like
therapy for me trying to understand why
my father does these things
does the things that he uh he does
and it was such a [ __ ] struggle and a
lot of the times too we forget that you
know when we're kind of in our own [ __ ]
and we're in our own pain we don't
really care about what somebody else is
going through yeah yeah so having to
deal with those emotions while you're
trying to better your life but still
kind of be mindful of them is another
[ __ ] struggle that you have to deal
with yeah i definitely realize that like
even though like we kind of view our
parents as like you're supposed to know
everything kind of kind of deal and like
it's like and it's like it's like you're
supposed to be able to like adjust for
me right
and um i think my therapist like was
saying like you know like it's a
learning process for both you and your
parent right it's like it's gonna take
some time and i think it just like
really hit or i was like you know like
all this time like i wanted my mom to
just understand like
i was like you know like like why isn't
she like just listening like to what i'm
saying like why is it that she keeps
asking the same thing over and over and
over again
and then it just kind of hit me i was
like you know i just want one day when
she asked that same question again i
don't have the reaction that i have now
which is like immediate like anger or
just like annoyance or whatever right
like i want to be able to like take it
in and be like oh that's mom you know
and just like take it in with like a
very light heart and be like that's just
who she is right i explained to my mom
because she has this one annoying
behavior where she has to get her way
yeah and i told her she goes and her
response to me after you know this was
not even that long it was like maybe a
couple months ago
and because we talk on the phone every
other day and i go hey you got to stop
doing that [ __ ] like that stuff annoys
the hell out of me and i don't want this
she goes well that's just how i am so
you have to deal with it and i said well
listen
i actually don't have to deal with it
i could just stop calling you yeah i'm
like you got to stop doing this stuff
and she goes well this is just the habit
that i have i was like well just because
it's something that you do doesn't mean
that it's good right and it doesn't mean
that people have to stay stay around for
it i was like you got to change the [ __ ]
i was like you have a very very short
temper i was like it's worse than mine
and every time people don't do the
things that you tell them to do you
decide that it's okay to just go off
yeah i'm like nah i'm not i'm not doing
that i said listen
you have 20 maybe 20 good years left in
this world right and i was like i have
another maybe
you know 40. yeah
those 20 years that that we're spending
together i wanted to be happy i don't
want to fight i don't want to do
anything else if you're telling me that
i have to stay around for your bad
behaviors because you don't want to
change it i'm not doing that yeah i was
like you got to stop doing this i was
like control this [ __ ] she goes i'm old
i can't change i was like i don't
believe that [ __ ] i was like you can
change you don't want to change because
it's uncomfortable because you feel that
because you have whatever x amount of
years that you've lived that you're done
like you're not done because we're still
going to have a relationship so unless
you want us to not talk on the phone
then you got to [ __ ] fix this thing
and so she says and basically what it
was that i told her that she likes to
complain about my habits too much on the
phone i was like when we talk if it's
just about you chastising me yeah we're
not having conversations yeah i'm like
you gotta you gotta bring something else
to the table besides you complaining
about the stuff that i'm not doing right
and so she's she's getting better she
goes well let me just complain a little
bit i'll say fine complain a little bit
but when i tell you it's too much you
have to stop she goes okay
let me just say this
okay so we kind of you know we meet in
the middle like so as long as she's
trying yeah i'm okay yeah if it's you're
wrong i'm not gonna try then hey guess
what when i have a kid
and i will not allow my child to be
around that right because now this is my
child
and so you have to respect these roles
if you don't respect me as an adult and
an individual you're not going to
respect that by the choices i have for
this kid that i have in the future yeah
and those look
those conversations are [ __ ] hard for
me guys
it's not easy i'm not telling you go out
there and do what i do it's easy no that
[ __ ] was uncomfortable it's hard for me
to talk to my parents like that it's
hard for me to tell this woman who
raised me as a child that this is what
you have to do to make our relationship
better because now i'm stepping into a
role as an equal
versus me as a child talking to a parent
right and that's uncomfortable
oh super
comfortable yeah it's weird that i have
to tell my parents these things it's
weird too for me as an adult that i have
to do things for my parents that they
were able to do their whole life but now
that they're all they can't do these are
like realities that are setting in for
me as a kid like my dad was telling me
the days like your mom's getting a
little more forgetful now that she's
older and i do a lot of things around
the house not because that i feel like i
have to or because i want to so i feel
like i have to because she's older now
she's not as strong as she used to be
yeah so
i don't i'm not thinking about this
because my thinking might i'm thinking
my parents are going to be around
forever right but my dad he doesn't
think that he sees her as her his wife
and he sees that my mom can't pick up
things as well as she used to she's
physically not as strong as she used to
yeah it used to be yeah you know that's
why when they retire they're retiring
this year like i'm going to be spending
a lot of like close time with them
that's good
because well she just you know asian
people they don't ever want to work on
their health the way that they're
supposed to you know
i'm like hey [ __ ] how about you stop
eating salt for breakfast
eat a [ __ ] vegetable that's not
cooked down
have a [ __ ] raw broccoli every now
and then but she said no no this is this
stuff is good for you it's just like a
pound of salt cause kimchi every every
korean side dish is salt yeah i'm like
hey stop and she go and like for him she
goes i eat healthier today i'm like what
did you eat she goes i just had melons
today i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] who said that that was healthier
it's so true like
when i see my parents i'm like oh my god
you guys are getting like so much older
and i'm like thinking about like how old
they are like my dad was born in 1950.
[ __ ] dude yeah he's like turning 72 this
year yeah my mom's around that age oh my
god it's like insane to me because i'm
like oh my god
you're so old and like you know and my
dad has been like really wholesome
lately like super wholesome like um i
would try to like take the dogs out like
around six
six to take them out to the park so they
can like run around and stuff like that
right and i've invited my dad to come
with me
and one time like that we did go i was
like hey you know you know that what
sounds really good right now and he's
like what has like a smoothie and he was
like oh yeah let's go get a smoothie
right and so now every time we walked
and i feel like it's become some sort of
like tradition or just a habit at this
point like every time we go and walk the
dogs he was like hey you want to get
smoothie first and then we'll go walk
the dogs and i'm like
oh that's so cute you know and like
there was another time where um
he was saying like that he needed a new
pair of glasses and he needed like the
progressive lenses where it's just like
that kind of like the bifocal but like a
more gradient kind of lens
and um he was telling me that he lost
this pair because i noticed he was
wearing a different pair and i told them
i was like oh yeah let's just go to this
glass place like gins you know like i
think they're great like they work for
like asian faces really really well
and um my dad was like okay yeah sure
and i was like well how much did your
other pair cost he was like 460 dollars
and i was like 460
is that with insurance and he was like
yeah i was like where did you get it and
he was like america's best i'm like oh
we're going to [ __ ] jen's like i
[ __ ] care like i'm taking you with me
right so i take him to like the santa
anita all and um he like tries out a
different bunch and like he was like
okay cool and we we get the we get the
glasses and it was 260 dollars yeah or
sorry sorry not 260 240 and it was like
they were having a sale i think that day
it was like 40 off it was like 240 bucks
for the lenses that he need and it fits
on his face better
and it was just insane and he was like
so star struck he was like oh my god i
can't believe it he kept looking at the
receipt
it was just really cute and people love
deals it gives him boaters he goes live
i'm having sex with your mom tonight i
saved two hundred dollars yeah
so like you know afterwards he was like
on thursday and i was like oh there's a
tea shop like in um in uh in the mall
like we'll just go there and then he saw
a dice when he went in and he had he had
a great time and his glasses were going
to come in like a month later and so
then when they came in he like called me
and he was like oh hey my glasses are
here do you want to go and uh pick them
up go to the mall pick them up and maybe
get some tea and i was like okay yeah
sure you know and i was just like oh my
god my dad's getting so old and he's
just like just like spending time i know
he does you know but like it's very rare
right but it was just like it was it was
a nice occasion and like with my mom
like
i spent time with her like in the
kitchen and i think there was like this
time where like she made chicken and
it's like been a long time you know
what's so weird actually your mom
actually fulfills the role of a typical
asian dad oh
dude yes i mean she's a tiger mom yeah
she's like that's very interesting yeah
because your mom my dad might be able to
dad and your dad reminds me of my mom
yeah my dad's literally a banana okay
yeah all right i mean he moved here when
he was 13. oh okay so he's like all
about murica man
yeah yeah yeah my mom she i think she
came in when she was like 19 20. okay
and here's the like a lot of like the
tradition it's like pretty pretty much
stuck to her but yeah like the other day
it was like my mom she made chicken
and it's been a while since she made
chicken right and it was like it was
pretty good and then she was like oh
here like have this uh dragon fruit i
was like okay yeah cool like i'll eat
this dragon fruit right and i did a
whole one and like that night i shat so
much i literally thought i was dying
like i literally thought i was dying and
i was just like what the hell is going
on like i shot earlier in the day why am
i [ __ ] again like i only do like
maybe like one driver [ __ ] you up like
that dude so then so the next morning i
come downstairs and my mom was like
washing dishes and she like looked at me
she's like hey did you poop and i was
like what are you talking about and then
she because i was like i don't know
where she's getting out with this
conversation and she was like you know
like she pooped you feel cleansed and i
was like
i did i poisoned you yeah and i was like
trying to make you skinnier
and i was like yes i did poop she's like
yeah geography would do that and i was
like that was a dragon fruit like i
thought i was literally died because i
thought it might have been food
poisoning with the chicken and i was
like oh my god and then she was like
yeah and i was like why didn't you tell
me she's like i thought you knew and i
was like [ __ ] i didn't know
yeah yeah so yeah if anyone is having
like uh digestive issues or constipation
dragon food is great just eat like a
third first get that tested out why
would your mom just give you something
that she knows is gonna make you explode
that's the funniest thing she goes you
know what
let's give her some dragon fruit she
needs to [ __ ] a little bit more today
it's so [ __ ] funny yeah well guys
that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast night is night
and short and sweet
went by so fast oh sorry are you gonna
start going you're not really doing
social media as much so uh no i tried to
do a little bit like kind of like test
it out to see how i feel about it i
think i think i'm going to try to post
one tick tock i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
the bar low it's just one tick tock hey
just tick tock just [ __ ] have fun
with it what was what's what's your um
uh instagram again ex blue apples x blue
apples with a z with a z at the end yeah
okay you can check julia chao on that
and you know hopefully she'll start her
youtube channel you know it's been about
[ __ ] 10 years but you know she'll
start it soon genius brain every sundays
at 12pm and we will catch you all next
time peace
[Music]